there's a clip of former republican
senator rick santorum making the rounds
in which he seems to either forget
or pretend not to remember that when
europeans came to what is now the united
states
there were native americans here already
there were
societies and cultures and communities
already
rick santorum is a really gross guy he's
been a cnn contributor for some time
since he left the senate
listen to what he had to say to the
young americas foundation
about the united states and its
uniqueness if you think about
this country i don't have any other
country in the world that was settled
predominantly by people who were coming
to practice their faith
they came here because they were not
allowed to practice their particular
faith in their own country
and so they came here mostly from europe
and they set up a country
that was based on judeo-christian
principles
i say judeo-chris the mosaic laws ten
commandments
and the teachings of jesus christ the
morale the morals and teachings of jesus
christ that's
that's what our founding documents are
based upon
it's in our dna you know if you think of
other countries like italy
and greece and china and turkey and
places like that
they've all sort of changed over time
i mean they've been they've been there
for sent for millennia
in many cases and their culture has sort
of evolved over time
but not us we came here
and created a blank slate we birthed a
nation
from nothing i mean there's nothing here
i mean yes we have native americans but
but candidly that that there isn't much
native american culture in american
culture
so there's a lot there and we will get
into it but what i was struck by
in watching the clip is how so much of
what these right-wingers
consider their values and principles are
based on faulty understandings of
history
where their logic is often functioning
in reverse
i'll give you an example rick santorum
says there isn't much native american
culture
in american culture he says that to
defend his claim
that there really wasn't anything here
when europeans came to what is now the
united states and
had what was here when they arrived been
more valuable
we would still see much more native
american cultural influence today
it's completely backwards reasoning
there isn't much native american culture
today
because native americans were widely
exterminated they're land taken
and we simply destroyed their culture
and overran it his reasoning is
the fact that not much of their culture
is left is
evidence that there wasn't much
interesting about it
when in fact the reason there isn't much
left is american settlers decided to get
rid of it
but it's a pretty grim insight into how
rick santorum views the people that were
here when european settlers arrived
which is
there wasn't much of value to him
based on his values which are the
judeo-christian stuff that he said
about the founding of the united states
of america the truth is there was
culture
there was infrastructure there were
communities there were customs
none of it was of any value to people
like rick santorum now if you're
interested in
learning more about this the book 1491
gives you a real sense of the americas
before european settlers landed but
there's this kind of interplay
between rick santorum's religious
beliefs serving as a justification for
what happened here
and what happened here then becomes a
justification for his religious views
it's this closed loop that can't be
broken doxastic closure
is the term i've used in the past to
describe it and then we get to the
bigger picture
message which is this is just another
example
of how these right-wingers are
incredibly staunch in their beliefs
because they think they know what those
beliefs are based on
but it turns out their beliefs are based
on misunderstandings and errors
it's you know i've talked i've jokingly
talked before about
what's the next principled stance ted
cruz will take
based on something he misheard or
misunderstood this
is a really tough cycle to break because
first you have to look at their premises
and take them down one by one
actually there were communities and
cultures and tons of things here
actually we're responsible for getting
rid of those things
and so actually the situation of the u.s
is getting to where it is today
isn't that unique and it's certainly not
particularly heroic
it has a lot of ugly in the past and it
has a ton of innovation
of course this applies to a lot of the
modern
right-wing set of beliefs taxes are bad
for the economy
and so democrats are bad for wanting
higher taxes and so the economy also
will do poorly under democrats whoa hold
on a second
actually well-calibrated and
well-balanced taxation is good for the
country
the stock market has done better under
democrats it's
a lot of work as many of you know who
have tried to convince
you know your crazy right-wing uncle at
thanksgiving it's a lot of work to get
people to change their minds on these
things and of course
this particular example for for rick
santorum also has him
it's all kind of draped in his religious
beliefs
both to justify his religious beliefs
and to glorify them and this is what
they do unless we tell people otherwise
and even when we tell people otherwise
often they keep doing it anyway
so this this is tough i've not found the
solution on this we've spoken to social
psychologists we've spoken to
um uh you know so many different people
about changing minds and when it's this
deep
it is very difficult and we're going to
see really a horrifying example of this
after the next dinner after the next
segment in the last segment of the show
a really horrible example of this from
tucker carlson unmasking so that's later
make sure you're following us on
instagram for more on this
story we are on instagram at david
pakman show
you can find me on instagram
david.pakman